Nhanh hỗ trợ phục hôn nếu mà sạch thay, nhiều chiến pháp từ thảo mục,
gế thể phó chết giải gói tinh lời,
an toàn, giúp làm việc ở vây thường đàn tôi đại,
hỗ trợ thái tạo và bảo vệ lực nêm mặt từ đó,
lạm giản vui cứ tại phói khi giữa giúp đường đàn.
Ông xa gát châu, lực miếng cứu bệnh lúc xa mê sài and comparison,
khăn là đà.
Sẵn xuất tại nhà máy đặt trưởng dì em đi với các phát ổng,
mối tất trưởng khách khai bây chất lượng và an toàn.
A sĩ tấn công như mặt,
với cùng, súc ổn định sạch giải lúc xa, giảm, mì cửa thái phát.
Nhân những ước tổ đỏ,
Ông xa đa châu, ngày cà được nhiều người,
là mùi đa zân văn phòng lượng trọt như một dẻ pháp an toàn.
Hương quả lâu dài cho bởi thế giạc thay,
bất khóc hộng hộng quả dân nghiệp sống khó lệm bệnh lây ra.
Để lại không thể lửa,
nhiều sức khỏe cũng cứu lực bỏ qua,
hãy chủ lượng bộ sống, Ông xa, giữa bối ngày,
để giải bụng an toàn tượng tượng tượng bữa an
và sống trọt như sống bắt nè.